when you get to this point right i hope
you all wrote a line like this
probably the most obvious thing to do is
to divide both sides
by two but when we meet simultaneous
equations right you generally have two
parts you can go through
you can solve by elimination right which
is like try and make them look
nice and then add or subtract each other
and then there's the other technique
what's the other one
substitution now you can probably see
here elimination's
not gonna help you because these two
equations are too
unalike for you to shape them in that
way but that's okay that's okay
i can divide both sides by something
like say
a and now this is an easy thing
to substitute in you can go one better
than that and say
i don't even have b in this i've got a b
squared right so if you want you could
do
that step here like so it wouldn't
matter you could do it here or you could
do it
when you do your substitution okay now
it is really important
if you've gotten to this spot here uh
you should label
what your equations are because the
simultaneous equations you want to
explain what's going on
i'm now going to substitute
2 that's this result into here
into one we want our logic and our
argument to be crystal clear
okay so rather than just calling this
equation two right away i worked with it
i made it look
exactly the way i wanted it before i
called it equation two
so now when i do my substitution i go a
squared there's the first bit
minus that that's b squared isn't it
minus three on
a squared which equals what do we say
was equal to negative two
yeah okay who got to this point and said
uh-oh what do i do with this now several
of you looked at it
but hopefully tried to press on just to
see what would happen what was the step
that you did to get from here
did you did you multiply by something
you're like ah fractions
gross okay you can get rid of the
fractions by multiplying by
a squared so you get this
and then you're like oh no oh no
this is um this doesn't look good right
stay with me you're 12. now here's the
thing
the four does look intimidating but
it is it truly is okay because if we
just get everything all on the one side
you'll see
you can think of this as something quite
easy to factorize if for example instead
of being a to the 4 if you had
u squared and if you had instead of a
squared just u
this is just a quadratic in fact you can
tell me what the factorization is what's
the pair of numbers you're after
plus three minus one plus three minus
one they will add to two
they'll multiply negative three thumbs
up it's just instead of a out the front
it's gonna be a
squared what do we say plus three minus
one how's that okay
now um i could factorize further if i
wanted but you know what
i'm just gonna pause remember and just
say what does this mean
if you've got a product between two
things and they apparently equal zero
then either
one or both of them must be equal zero
do you agree because there's no other
way you can get a product of zero
okay now i could try and make this equal
to zero
okay but just pause remember before you
start thinking
i can do complex numbers i know what to
do with this
just pause because what is a again
what is it a is a is the real part of my
complex number
so it had better not be imaginary
itself does that make sense in fact all
the way at the beginning of this topic
we said
a and b are defined as real numbers
otherwise the real part's not real and
the imaginary part's not imaginary okay
so therefore i can say there is actually
no and you have the right language this
right
no real solution from this okay no real
solution
but this other side does give you a real
solution doesn't it
clearly if a squared minus 1 equals 0 a
is going to give you
plus or minus 1. and from there you can
go back over here
right plus minus one when a is negative
one
b will equal have a look
this is where i'm substituting into
minus
negative root three yes and when a is 1
then b is going to be
positive root 3. remember are you okay
with that
so i have solutions z is equal to
i'll put it back in rectangular form
because that's how it was presented to
me
here's my first one minus 1 minus root 3
i because that's the imaginary component
or the positive version
okay now as promised this was just one
of two methods to do this right this was
the rectangular
way to go about it uh it was you know
a little secure to us but it used
mathematics that we knew right it used
some tennis equations this comparison
thinking carefully and solving
okay now i said to you before i'm going
to leave this as an exercise to you
we can think about this right from the
outset not in rectangular form
but yeah you said like why don't we put
this into exponential form i didn't
choose these numbers by accident
i'd like you now remember this time
you'll have enough time to do this
other method you'll arrive at the same
answers and then you can get on a canvas
and have a look at the rest of the
exercise
how would you go about doing this in
exponential form i give you a clue
you need to start with a number that's
written in exponential form okay
mrs lee's just before we head on um i
know that a lot of you wrote plus or
minus
your answer in this case that's okay but
sometimes
the positive a is going to go with the
negative b
and you need to really make it clear
which your partnership is
so if you just always lie here plus
minus one plus minus three
make sure you know which way round they
go because they don't always go plus
plus minus minus
oh yeah i just want you to be super
careful
and that's why laying it out and laying
it out
makes that abundantly clean as just as
this point out i
very deliberately even the
mathematicians are famously lazy
we also have a big thing about
communicating clearly
and unambiguously right now sometimes
you will see
in fact i think one version of the
reference sheet in the past actually
used
this notation which is exactly what mrs
leaves is just talking about when the
plus minus of one
matches with the opposite sign of the
other one this notation is used you'll
sometimes see it
i'm just going to go out there and say i
don't like it because people look at
they're like what the heck does that
mean
you you come up with it so infrequently
that comparing that to something like
this where i just write my signs
properly
this just wins hands down and you know
if if you really want to roll the dice
you might meet some hsc mark and be like
what on earth is that and then tough
that was the only hsc mark you got and
you never find out okay
so this is definitely the clearest and
biggest way to do it
so for those of you who didn't get there
just let me walk you through
the way i thought about this okay
to do this in exponential form as i
mentioned earlier the first thing you
got to do
is get the complex number provided to
you written in exponential form rather
than rectangular so you can see that
uh over here on the top right hand
corner i had to find my modulus
had to find my argument some of you who
i showed this to earlier said like do we
have to have a diagram
the answer is the question did not ask
for a diagram but
i find it so helpful when working out
what my
modulus and arguments are particularly
the argument because i'm like i don't
know is it negative like which is the
principle one
it just seems to me so much of an easier
way to think about it
that i often draw a diagram even when
it's not required of me it is a very
very convincing argument for the marker
and for you as well once you've got that
you can see i've rewritten z
as four e to the i two pi on three and
then from there
it's almost like that form of number was
designed to make
questions like this easy to deal with
right you can see i've
i think i don't know why i used w
instead of z maybe because i was
separating my working out but
um you can see i've just factorized
using difference of squares
do you see my line there w squared
equals four e to the
etc right so then you've got it's
something squared take away
something else squared you just have to
rewrite it in a form
which is what i've done on this third
last line to show what's being
squared to get four you square two with
the indices
to get to two pi and three because it's
being doubled you have it right
so that's why it's pi and 3 on the
inside and you multiply by 2.
from there you can see my factorization
and then here is my answer now
unlike in rectangular form it does make
sense to just put the plus minus out the
front it's completely unambiguous
what that means okay so this is a more
concise way to write it
but i do want to point out it works
nicely because of the particular complex
number
i hated you it's got a nice argument if
i gave you a number which the exercise
frequently will
which has a weird non-exact value like
what's the angle
in my 6 8 10 triangle i don't know okay
so
if you've got a number like that use the
rectangular form that's totally fine
but the whole point is we have access to
these tools and part of the skill set we
want you to develop is
which one is the most appropriate and
pick the right one make sense
exercise 1b uh make sure you have a look
at the questions that are in
the calendar i know a bunch of you have
so many questions to me and i'll work on
them to
send you guys on the page this is
meant by liz method okay
so by inspection is an extension to
student's
favorite phrase it basically means i
looked at it
and my brain told me the answer was this
now you've actually been doing this for
quite some time for example
you did it right here do you see that
you're like
oh this was me looking at this and
realizing i know these numbers
sufficiently well
to just say the pair of like i didn't
like there was not a big argument
of logic of like how did i get from here
to here okay now when they say
by inspection they're asking like
they're handing you a number that should
be
easy like this is a bit of a messy
number right it's a number that you're
going to be able to say
if i think about where the modulus is
and where the argument is i can halve
the argument
because then you double it to get to
there and i take the square root
of whatever the modulus is because you
can see that's how i get from
uh what do we say modulus of four two
modulus of two that's what happens when
you take the square root of the modulus
so that's only for numbers that are nice
and easy which is why the textbook on
that question gives you convenient ones
for the rest of them you're going to
have to bring out the big guns okay
thank you year 12.